the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free to make a donation or view
additional materials from hundreds of
MIT courses visit MIT opencourseware at
ocw.mit.edu ok just a few announcements
before we get into lecture today so a
structure for today our lecture two
hours work in your in your groups we
have unfortunately L the grad student is
working with the heat wave would be
using a heat wave game is sick today so
she won't be able to come in but i'm
working on rescheduling a time for her
to come in on what i'd like to love to
do is if we can get her a a web link of
the heat wave game that she can then
give you feedback on that might be good
for you guys for y'all for the rest of
the class we've got Pablo in today he
talked to the stamp team already I is he
going to talk to you again today are you
guys all on the right page with him ok
oh you didn't show him the game then ok
cool cool so he's going to take a look
at what I'd like going to do is talk to
take a look at the forecast based future
game on today if you can i'm at two
o'clock I'm just show him a build get
some feedback from him and then he'll
take a look at the snap game and then if
he's got time the two cholera games you
can take a look at those and again if
you want to give him web links to the
two playable versions of the games just
send them to the video game bosses list
and all for them on other announcements
we have so this friday and i'm going to
email this to the announcements list
later today this friday there is a free
conference workshop thing going on at a
hotel I think in Boston but it's being
run by epic games about unreal so
they're going to do a bunch of different
workshops from about two to five and end
the day with a networking party so if
you're interested in using the Unreal
Engine I've been all the different new
things about that engine they'll be
running that they're also going to be on
campus Tuesday
at 5pm to Tuesday November eighteenth
that can be found at the game lab
website and they'll be talking about
blueprint the way to do scripting and
unreal that's kind of similar to some
things I've seen and for unity but it's
baked into unreal and if you use
previous versions of in rail I think
it's related to kismet if you use that
tool before otherwise upcoming guests we
have the class that are different from
the syllabus on Monday we're going to
have two writers and talking with drew
doing a little panel and then a queue
and I with y'all talking about different
ask different ways of looking at writing
for games but I think it would be very
directly related to at least two of the
games that I've seen as ears of yours
very dialogue driven game yeah and then
the Animal Crossing kind of game I
imagine be it'd be really useful for you
all probably useful for the other two as
well but those are the ones that I first
came to my mind when I was scheduling
that one and then on the 19th right
we've blizzard coming in right yeah yeah
so wednesday 19th blizzards going to
come in and it's teams from heroes of
the storm but yeah we're not quite sure
exactly who's gonna who's going to be
there for that but we talked to them and
we requested either heroes of the storm
or hearthstone so one of those one of
those groups on will began to talk about
their production process and you can ask
them things about what it's like to work
at blizzard um that's everything I've
got yep so I'm going to bring it over to
to your wired cool great so uh when I
went over to GDC next just last week I
met Richard actually he's been to our
lab before and he gave this talk on game
audio and then I remembered wait a
minute it's a talking game audio that's
coming up in class and I was just going
to fake it and then I heard his talk and
realized maybe he should be the one
talking to you instead so I invited him
and Eddie fossberg who's his partner at
hex any audio let's see you you'll see
the name of the company come up in the
next slide and there are they do
professional sound design and all you
design and music know that includes
things like sound effects as well as
scoring and also advising companies on
things like the technology that you are
using and he's going to talk a little
bit about how to do good audio on a
budget as well that's just things to
think about in your audio design of your
own game so I'm gonna head it over to
you I thank you very much for speaking
today yeah well thanks so much happy to
be here just curious the sort of class
I'm wondering what what level is it is
it more introductory advanced what's the
focus intermediate soda making video
games but it's a class that actually has
prerequisites so they needed to take
other classes either in game design or
in programming before they came out
there oh cool so I'm just like show of
hands how many people like are planning
to go out into the world after you
graduate and become game designers game
developers anyone anyone okay cool cool
thanks that's it sweet no very nice
great so yeah we're gonna you know talk
to you about music and sound in games
and then give it a little bit of very
practical advice about working with
composers and working with sound
designers since that's the the situation
most of you will probably be in so we'll
give you a little overview of ourselves
in a second but if you want to go on to
the next slide you know we're gonna talk
about three key areas um yeah we're just
gonna tag-team this you know like we
were just going to like so the three
things are going to talk about our
number one interactivity so we're going
to talk to you about what makes game
audio different than film audio and why
you should care about it and then in
agreements we're going to talk about
contracts you know what that looks like
for you hiring a composer or a sound
designer which is really most often the
case with an indie game and then lastly
we'll talk about money and budgets you
know and how much hiring one of us or
you know audio guys takes so um yeah
yeah a little bit about us I'm Richard
Ludlow again and I'm the audio director
at our company and Andy is the music
director hmm yeah and you both went to
school in Boston actually yeah just
across the river over at Berkeley and
did their game audio thing and now we
started the company hex new audio and
basically you
music sound and dialogue as well as
implementation services are what we do
with our clients so another base in Los
Angeles obviously yeah based in LA and
we have a you know we experience working
on you know larger triple-a console
games lots of mobile indie things so
really wide range and we do film and
commercial media as well but our focus
really is on games and interactivity and
the technology that drives that so um
yeah without further ado you know if you
want to jump ahead to the basics so uh
yeah yeah absolutely so um you know
music and games is all about dynamic the
dynamic experience and player in the
game and how the music and sound effects
adapt around that obviously it's much
different than linear media such as film
TV etc when you watch a film that same
explosion is to happen in the same point
every time so obviously with James we
have to change that because games are
different and we have to make it
adaptive to what's going on so there's
four major parts to audio in a game
usually there's the music there's the
sound and the dialogue with the major
part of this again is the implementation
into the game if we write amazing music
or sound effects or we have the coolest
voiceover artist in the world and we get
them do that stuff for our game if we
implement it incorrectly or the
developer doesn't do such a great job
because there wasn't a dialogue between
us then all the stuff on the left side
those three things almost don't even
matter you know so it's all about that
how it gets put in the game as well as
how it's crafted so and we're going to
talk about that in the interactivity
section if you're like you know what is
this implementation in witchcraft we
speak up exactly anyway next slide yeah
so the importance of audio you know
really talking about why you guys should
care about audio because you know so
often you know you think ok I've got
this mobile game I'm going to shut off
the audio who cares about it but you
know there the depth that adds is really
important you know we just like to touch
on three key areas of why music and
sound is so important games that the
first thing obviously the emotional
factor and I mean you can't get around
that basically you know with everything
else it basically audio
straight to the center of your brain
that controls that stuff it just gives
everything else and stimulates that so
obviously i mean if when we were kids
you know we turn we turn the music off
of a game or turn the music off of the
film and we'd realize that we weren't
having those emotional responses that we
did when it was on so obviously emotion
is a huge part of what we do yeah and
that that's you know that's like a
chemical response like eye candy said
you know it's like actually eliciting
just to emphasize again like a chemical
response visuals do not trigger these
emotional processing center yeah it's
like sound and music that's stimulating
parts of your brains are like different
and actually creating the emotion it's
pretty amazing at least we like yeah
anyway so the next one is like function
you know and this isn't a great term but
audio it supports the the ability for
the player to really absorb a lot of the
game information so when I say function
you know it it has the function of
giving you information and also the
function of telling you you know what's
going on with regards to your actions so
for example you're walking down the
hallway and you've got um in your ear
there's a guy up ahead that you hear you
know maybe walking and you know okay
there's a guard up ahead and then maybe
your oxygen tank is running low and
you've got a little beep and your health
is you know maybe a 50-percent maybe
there's an alarm going off in the
building you hear a guy in the next room
ah you know your ear you hear all these
different things and all of that is
information that's being processed and
sent to you and you're able to absorb it
all instantly without needing to think
and see like text on the screen that
says okay I'm like at fifty percent
oxygen there's three enemies nearby you
know it's getting dark out because I
hear the crickets this is just stuff
that your brain like the subconsciously
absorbs so it's functional and it
provides that information for players in
an entirely new dimension that is
subconscious to them so you can convey
lots of subconscious information exactly
and then also if that feel good factor
for games so you know you
punch a guy and uh oh well hold up on
that may be but you but yeah you punch a
guy and it feels like it you know it
feels good in the game you know in that
that is because of that ax that trigger
you know the the sound meshing with the
you know the psychological and anyway so
the sounds you know we're talking about
that are memorable I know you just
played what was that like the Zelda
sound or something oh yeah I couldn't
quite hear obviously yeah it obviously
has to be memorable game audio as well
and like yet play the zelda 1 think of
the countdown for mario kart we're
making one hit a really fast and get
everyone obviously um but there's
there's countless examples um we might
have you can just play them all just
blame all let's see i'm not sure if
you've played them but i'll just funny
though so I mean these these are really
iconic sounds and I think the Mario coin
sound is next let's see hey yeah so you
don't like that's an entire generation
of games and it and you know Zelda sound
like when you hear that that's like
extremely blue boarding to the player
it's extremely memorable sound is like
burned into a player's conscience and
you know in a way that is it but that
doesn't necessarily happen with visuals
like you hear that and you hear the
achievement sound that we played it's
like out I've on locked that there's
like this this you know stimulating
reward response that's and so good sound
and bad sound is going to stick with
your players and and it can really help
you know set that game apart so that
later on you know you're the players are
remembering your game in a very unique
way yeah anyway next slow move on to the
real stuff now so interactivity you know
that was kind of the preface so the
first section that we talked about is
you know that implementation and how
that works in games and interactivity is
a huge part of that so if you want to
jump ahead to the next slide oh yeah so
on the music side of things obviously we
want music that changes dynamically
based on what the player is doing
whether he's walking in the field and
staying
for five hours because he left it on to
go make a sandwich or because he's
walking in to buy something from a
shopkeeper so how do we do that there's
several different things we can do on
whether player is going into battle etc
um we can use one system called layering
which Richards going to talk about
another slide um we're going to talk
about cross fading and then you're going
to give you an example of branching as
well another is also generative and
these are just a few there's so many
there's so many options that we can use
to implement music in a cool interactive
way so yeah so let's jump over to one of
the examples and go ahead and throw that
up don't hit the play button quite yet
so ah you can you can hit the next slide
and will pop up the graph great so um
what you're seeing here is a the idea of
a layered score so in this one I this is
a piece of music I wrote for game where
there's three different intensity layers
and you're going to hear a first one
that's very you know low intensity and
then you're going to hear these other
layers come in on top as maybe the
player you know starts to go into an
area with enemies and then they go into
an area where there in battle and you'll
hear the music kind of stack in a very
dynamic way anyway go ahead and hit play
let's see
see that one city
clears the second
you're all doing
just the first two interests the first
so you can see this was like you can
hear the layers fading out in between
one another but it was a very dynamic
experience so this is where we'd like
take the music and we'd specifically
craft it and write it so that these
things could stack and be triggered
dynamically based on whatever the
players doing so let's jump ahead to the
next slide so this is one more example
and this is the last one will show you
for music that deals with the way that
music can move dynamically between
states again so yeah so we've got the
low medium high but this time we've
broken it out into smaller little chunks
so the player will do something and the
music will actually wait until a musical
point like the next bar or beat and then
it will begin a transitional segment
into the next level intensity stand this
is going to be a much more dynamic and
fluid experience than the layering so go
ahead and hit play low intensity again
so players going to do something and
it's going to come in with the
transition transition
going to medium and medium
you
and back the low cool so you saw the
music move through one two three four
six different pieces they're all but it
sounded like the experience was being
scored so again the idea here is you
know we're trying to you know again with
the film you watch it it goes by you
know what's going to happen we don't
know what's going to happen with the
game so we write music that can change
and adapt like that in a very film like
way to score the player experience so
you know why do we do this so obviously
it creates a more immersive and I know
until you experience any time we are
taking you guys out of that escapist
experience like we're not doing our job
it extends track longevity which I will
explain later with budgets why that's
nice as well um but you get better
replay value out of it and it's the
greatest value from each individual
minute of music yeah so instead of
having to write you know hire someone to
write three different pieces of music if
you're on a budget you can say we'll do
one piece of music and we'll make it
layered and it'll be one better piece of
news exactly cuz like something like if
if a movie is 90 minutes long and they
want 60 minutes of music you write 60
minutes of music one small mobile game
could have 15 minutes of music or I
could have one minute of music or three
minutes of music so it all depends yeah
and that you know that goes into we'll
talk about with budgets how that affects
that but um you know so yeah I'm jumping
onto the next slide you know how do we
do these these interactive systems we
build them with what we call audio
middleware and two of the commercial
ones RF mod that you see here and if you
want to jump ahead to the next one wise
and these are just screenshots and
essentially these allow us to interface
with programmers and set up these
musical triggers and these points of you
know musical change based on different
parameters like number of enemies around
or game state or help and let us set up
these musical transitions and things
like that so yeah we can jump on to the
next section agreements yeah so you know
you've you've learned all about
interactivity and you're like yes this
is awesome i'm going to hire a game
composer so that they can do this stuff
and then you know the with music though
it's a very you know it's obviously
creative piece of content so the
agreements look
a little different sometimes than other
agreements and so we're going to show
you three different kinds yeah so the
purposes of these contracts are
obviously to see who owns it obviously
first and foremost what we're going to
be delivering to you what the delivery
milestones are in a game just is there's
development milestones on how much you
guys are paying which is super important
for you and us and uh you know what's
your rights is a developer where can you
use it can you around and license it to
use it and all the things involved with
your project or no and what are our uses
usage rights can we use it in our
portfolio on our Facebook page can we do
that sort of thing so on so look we're
just going to go through a few the
contract types here so yeah and it's
it's really important to spell out all
those things so yeah let's look at the
first one um work for hire you know this
is the most common type of agreement
that you run into with composers and
it's essentially where I'm the composer
I've written music and I am selling you
my music or sound you're buying it from
me and you're taking all the rights for
it as a developer you become the owners
of the music and sound and you know this
is the most and so you've got the rights
associated with it and because you have
the rights the developer then can
usually use the audio however they want
in the project because you own it um
you've also got the exclusive right to
use the audio meaning you're the only
ones that can use it I can't go around
turn around and sell it to Bob or Joe
over there you bought it it's yours and
then lastly you know this is a
disadvantage for developers is that this
is a more expensive agreement because
you are buying out all of our rights and
and I'm going to show in detail in a few
slides some important clauses to be
aware of in these contracts but yeah so
let's talk about on the other end of the
spectrum we've got work for hire where
you I me the composer's selling the
developer my rights and then on the
other end of the spectrum we've got
licenses great so we have two sorts of
licenses the first we'll talk about is
the non-exclusive so this means that we
are retaining the rights of the music
sound effects anything we do for your
project we can go around and turn it to
another game etc however don't be afraid
of these we're writing the same custom
music for your game which is super
important to remember you're getting the
same
exact product um it's obviously a lot
cheaper and it's a great way to save
your guys you yourself some money when
working with people like us um and again
you can still have unrestricted use of
the audio in your project and things
involved with that usually but you know
again we could turn around and use this
for whatever we would like to use it for
on so yeah those are the makeup and we
use this negotiating with with
developers all the time you know so if
they don't want to buy out all of our
rights and pay that full price will say
okay well we'll retain the right to go
sell it to Bob and Joe and still give
you the same music yeah so that um yeah
and then we have obviously the exclusive
license which is we're going to well
you're going to retain all the rights
but it's usually for a certain amount of
time and then those rights transfer back
to us and sometimes it's
industry-specific so we might be able to
use that audio in a trailer or a film or
something however pertaining to the game
or anything in the game world we're not
going to turn around and license that to
someone else usually this lasts about
125 years we like to call this the happy
medium you know between the work for
hire and the exclusion they exclude the
non-exclusive license it really is a
healthy balance of price and control
because it's right in the middle as far
as price is concerned yeah and
everyone's kind of happy you guys could
use it for what you need but then we
also get those rights back of entropy so
yeah so work for hire I make the music
I'm the composer I sell it to you you
get all the rights non-exclusive I'm the
composer I make the music I retain all
the rights and i can sell it to other
people exclusive I'm the composer I make
the music I retain the rights but I give
you the exclusive right to it so I can't
sell it to anyone else and then it
usually reverts back to us after your
time yeah or uh yeah let's discuss so
most common though is the work for hire
and you're like seeing that contract
you're like oh my god this is awful I
don't want to see this but anyway uh so
yeah let's jump through that really
quick just a few key points that really
you know go to developers helping
protect themselves and I'm know I gotta
hit play over here on my keynote so that
I can see all the different slide
changes one second
okay cool so the first thing you know
services it's like you know what are you
paying for at music sound dialogue what
are you buying this will be really quick
jumping on to the next zone so payment
for services what are you getting paid
you want to spell out exactly how much
you're going to charge and how much
you're going to pay for the music and
sound next contract and this is it our
next point and this is the independent
contractor point that's important for
you as a developer because this
essentially says that the composer or
sound designer you're hiring is not on
salary and does not need benefits they
have to you know take care of their own
taxes it just protects the developers so
they're a little as make everything
clear their next warranties these are
things again that protect you as the
developer so this says okay the music
we're writing its original we're not
stealing John willing to music as I
always let's go over again yes right but
that not if we do steal it you know and
we're not going to seal it and there's
some other warranties as well but we'll
jump onto the end femina fication ah so
then it usually says if we do steal John
woos music you guys are protected and
there's different levels of
indemnification but the indemnification
just says it falls on us if we screw
things up next is usually a little
confident shal information clause little
MDA clause about not disclosing things
and then some specific legal language
about the ownership and assignment of
Rights specific to work for hire legal
mumbo jumbo um we'll skip the
subcontracting and then there's some
rights that are specific to us as the
content creators so if you remember we
talked about poser specific rights
things like the ability for us to post
our work on our website something that
we like in our contracts so that we can
advertise you know music to other people
will tick of them to hire us similarly
we often spell out how we're going to be
credited and the credit is a great way
you know it's about to negotiate with
your composure if you're on a budget you
know maybe you say okay I'll put your
name at the opening cinematic instead of
you know just in the back you know
because
to help compensate our lack of budget
get you a little more exposure things
like that so you spell out how you want
to be credited on that that's really it
for the contract I don't want to go to
detail there but you know some key
points to be thinking about if you guys
ever hire a composer or sound designer
let's talk about money young you know
this is the question most most people
have what what and you know hi whenever
I meet a developer like without fail
within like 10 minutes of the
conversation they're like ah what do you
charge what'swhat's like general charge
late again it's funny I gave it and I
give this talk at GGC next and you'll
see by the end of it why I'm like that's
not a question I can just answer but and
then I got like three emails from people
who attended the talk after and who were
like can you just give me a range for
like an indie budget anyway but you'll
see why that's funny a minute because my
response is always to them you know when
they ask how much do you charge my
response is always what's your budget
and the reason being because there are
so many factors oh yeah I know whether
the deadline is a musical style whether
or not you know we're talking about a
solo piano piece versus epic orchestral
piece are we going to get live players
hey that orchestral those orchestral
pieces or in a player to play that you
can throw up the bullet points if you
want just FYI we're uh we're just going
throne anyway and you know what's the
release platform is this a triple a
console or is it a facebook game for the
american cancer society again are we
going to use my work for hire one of the
license feels right you know i mean like
we just talked about buying out the
rights or us keeping the rights really
big effect on the price there yeah um
how much are you buying you know we're
like Costco I'm or and safe but if
you're gonna buy 500 sound effects it's
obviously going to be different than if
you need 5 7 250 sound effects yeah we
get bulk discounts all the time exactly
and that goes into obviously the depth
of body of experience as well which is
you know how crazy we're going to get
with interactivity uh if we're going to
be using middle Claire uh like any set
with the mobile game you know you could
put one minute three minutes 10 minutes
20 minutes all in the same game it's
going to be a better game if you've got
you know maybe you don't need 20 but if
you've got more than one looping track
it's going to be a better game but the
game
exists with a single piece of music so
saying how much do you charge is a very
very difficult question to answer
without knowing more about your game
yeah one of one of our clients on that
we work with on their page where you go
to contact them it's just when do you
need your project done by one of the
options is yesterday yeah that deadlines
are huge part of that you know like
sometimes we get calls where it's like
we need this in two days or in a day and
you know we'll do it that's but it's
going to cost more than if you need it
in a year yeah um so you know contacting
guys early is is is important so anyway
let's jump on to payment mom and you can
hit all these bullet points yeah yeah I
am you know you know just basically
talking about ow composers and sound
designers charge you know typically with
music it's a permanent music so not per
minute that working but yeah and sound
effects yeah and then sound effects are
usually her assets so yeah or sometimes
a flat fee that's also coming to be my
quota project and say okay I'll do your
whole project regardless of how many
sound effects for you know twenty
thousand dollars i don't know sometimes
hourly rate we usually don't do this
this is a really hard one to gauge so
you it's a valid thing people do it we
don't we don't but um yeah um some like
weird thing happening below us sorry um
and then uh usually uh we really like to
try to get back and profit-sharing you
know if we it isn't yeah that's a big
thing but with audio to think about i'm
at the end of days is it really gonna
cost that much to give point five
percent of back end when you can't give
anything up front cuz we always have
passion project you know we've made
money on some of the projects but we
really like to believe in games that are
really cool and sometimes about job to
do that it's just a shared game the
indie scene you know like they often
can't afford because they don't have
that upfront money and so we'll talk
about a back-end profit sharing
percentage and you know if you talk to
people who have been doing this like 30
years that didn't exist like 10 20 30
years ago like audio guys did not get
back in profit sharing usually because
they were just paid up front but that's
kind of gone away you know in
guess that kind of probably true of a
lot of all industries but but I you know
that that you know so thinking about
that it's a very you know valid thing
and you know you it's usually
accompanied by some upfront fee it's
usually reduced amount but uh you know
the back end thing is definitely valid
we want you know new developers to be
you know less afraid of that and more
open to it yeah absolutely um and then
any combination of the above do cool
anyway um so so how does this kind of
break down and you can throw all these
up here you know just showing you a
music sound and dialogue you know
there's a lot of components here so when
we're talking about what we're charging
we charge different prices for themes in
the music so I write a physical feat
that has no it's it's setting and we
card one price for that but then we
might put an arrangement of that in an
underwater level a desert level of
jungle level the same theme but
different arrangements for different
levels and we charge less those
arrangements those little transitional
segments you heard in that in that demo
I play those are transitions we charge
less for those and n even different
price for things like stingers like I
coin pickup or an end game like don't
own the sound like that you die with
sound effects we break things out into
primary sound effects like if about a
creature having an attack sound and then
it's like dice fountain idle sound those
are all kind of primary sounds
iterations might be like a tackle one
attack Oh to attack 03 died 01 died 02
and we charge less for iterations UI and
ambiences different prices there and
then dialogue is just a whole slew of
components like casting different you
know usually hire someone to cast all
the actors getting Evans fake seeker
than I thought duty game order where
it's basically for the next day in
ourselves what doesn't want to use Kevin
Spacey but you're right and then so they
charge you know a few hundred a few
thousand an hour depending on the actor
usually there's somewhat directing them
while they're being recorded someone
courting them editing them processing
there's a you know just throwing this up
here so you know all the different
components of music
sound that are out there so again asking
what do you charge what is your game
need is a you know very I we need to
know what your game neat or we can say
the next slide yeah so we're getting
close to the end here and we can do some
questions but just talking about like a
theoretical project so you've got a low
budget 160,000 our Kickstarter project
and I like and I remember so so talking
about sound we're typically looking at
like five to fifteen percent a budget
being allocated to audio five to fifteen
usually hovering around 10 15 20 25 very
good what are good no but seriously um
and so a common problem with this though
is that your game to be awesome needs
like this much use but your budget is
only going to allow for this much music
so let's say we've got a hypothetical
game here that where a project might
need 18 minutes music and 300 sound
effects so say we were going to charge
you know like 750 minute for themes and
500 a minute for arrangements which are
you know kind of indie prices um you
know we charge up to like a we do a
different scale because of all the
different factors involved but no up to
like a thousand dollars a minute is um
it's pretty typical you know big guys on
triple A's will be charging at 2,500 a
minute but you know up to a thousand
opinion of music is pretty typical
between 500,000 and and then maybe you
know sound effects may be a combination
of all those kind of total 12,500 let's
say this came to be awesome again needs
twenty-three thousand five hundred
dollars for the audio and you're like oh
my god that's a lot of money and let's
take the developer has only allocated
11,000 to audio right so some things we
can do to reduce the cost around we can
reduce the original music themes and
increase the arrangements so we can just
do a lot of iterations things which is
actually a very feasible option because
this composers were trained to do that
I'm we can reduce the number of sound
effects iterations just have more of
those primaries only attack 01 and sec
about two or three or four exactly on we
can do back in private charities I
mentioned before so maybe you have three
percent on that and then we could use a
license agreement
say you're using the work for hire so so
yeah just some common thing is you know
to think about in that negotiating
process about how can we work with the
audio guy to reduce the cost to
something we're both comfortable um yeah
so let's just wrap up really quick you
know when we talk about interactivity
its music its sound it's responding
dynamically to player input the player
does something music the sound it
changes the axe I going to create a
deeper experience going to reduce the
cost if you do it right and we're doing
this with f mod wise fabric different
audio middleware I'm and then for
budgets you know from trying to look at
five to fifteen percent of the total
budget of your game allocated to audio
remember to consider back-end payments
we really think that's going to be part
of the future of how audio works within
especially the indie market and I'm just
be willing to negotiate and figure
things out you know um your costs
fluctuate our cost fluctuates so it
needs to be a negotiation we can easily
figure something out any audio person
can yeah owenton we jumped over
agreements but I don't know it's right
now it's all good no um and then
agreements again you know we're talking
about work for hire I'm the composer I'm
writing the music you as the developer
are buying it licenses I'm the composer
I write music I obtained the rights and
then I get you some type of license to
use the zoo but um you know that that
kind of wraps up I think note that the
core points are going to talk about um I
don't if you guys have specific
questions we're happy to answer them or
Phillip you have any additional you know
points you want to touch on
okay i think for questions if anyone has
any questions I'll repeat it so that I'm
since I'm a little bit closer to the mic
although maybe the mic might pick you up
if you're in the back of the room we'll
get a shot it doesn't need to be a
question about what we talked about to
you know any audio related thing color
yeah s loud it's okay
do you measure catch I think so so was
the gist of it basically being folks
using music and sound and then getting
takedown notices is that what you said
download the notices on services like
YouTube which yeah absolutely so then
i'll take the unnoticed thing has really
come about because you know people are
just using the music or just using the
sound without asking for permission it
for now in an actual gameplay video if
you're streaming twitch like that is
really a very developer specific
question and that's not something that
we as the composers and sound designers
really even have control over yeah you
know if it's for a game and if it's in a
game you know if we're working on a
Nintendo game and it goes out to them
then that is owned by Nintendo and if
it's not owned by Nintendo they've got
the license for it so it's all on them
with regards to that you know so some
developers are totally cool letting it
slide some developers are not but that's
really you know uh it's a shifting that
it's all being figured out usually that
happens obviously in the bigger game
world I mean you're not looking at I
mean that might happen like the biggest
game that would probably happen within
the new world would be something like
journey or something like that but and
you know most often at least now
developers are you know pretty cool with
it but I know there you know that it's
it's all being figured out right now
that's a very shifting Lansky's to do
with royalty using music yeah that's
another thing there's like easy like
collections have been set up for film
and TV for eons now here's a system in
place for that but there's really no
landscape for games it's a little
different with YouTube and then twitch
as well you know like we get paid point
zero zero zero one sense every time
someone watch something on YouTube so
you'll stay in five years hopefully that
will all be figured out but sorry I
don't have a better answer it's not our
fault it's the developer just just a
follow-up question on that it seems like
in order for all these services to
actually detect that they're using the
music they need to cross check it
against some sort of audio database so
is that something that you as composers
usually end up submitting or is that
something that the game companies
usually end up doing or does it really
depend on license
that you have with the with the company
it's usually the game it's usually the
developer yeah I guess so I mean there's
there's a there's a couple different
ways we have friends who work for for
playstation and they were just talking
about how they posted things on their
PlayStation america north america
account and they got taken down by a
playstation like Japan or something so
own your own companies aren't even
really able to quite mesh this together
yet but you know there's there's the
databases are sometimes internal to
publishers but they're also sometimes
you know there's scanning services that
uh that these royalty agencies like BMI
and ASCAP actually have and they've got
these automatic scanning their setup and
that sometimes comes about because we
submit our music to these royalty
agencies like as Captain beat my in
order to be able to get paid but then
they use them to find out how many times
things are getting played they don't use
them to figure out like what should be
taken down so I things actly yeah I
think like especially like it and then
on the ND level like if the only way we
would be able to detect something as if
we went wash youtube video our music was
in it we're like oh crap yeah we don't
have like these these engines going you
know those are like the publishers have
the teams of people doing takedowns on
their content so dat yeah and I don't
know all the details behind Matt but uh
that's right but I sorry the the ASCAP
stands for American Society of Composers
impoverish publishers i want to say cup
uh I think I'm publish yeah we're we
just got the enzyme Myers broadcast
rated right yeah so I can take a look at
it they're called pyara oats Composers
Authors and publishers yes other
questions you know this
yeah yeah we do those all the time and
that's a totally legitimate thing you
know if you aren't sure asking them to
do like a one minute demo or like a 30
second demo one minute it can be like
you know but I'd say like a 30 second
demo is totally legitimate um not yeah
and usually the best way to do that
guy's just so you know take some
gameplay be it from your game a
different game concept art for your game
okay take some visuals as a video send
it to them or just concept art send it
to them and let them work with that we
can even we could even do an interactive
demo for it at that point that you know
the big thing again is there's
difference between being able to write
good music and having a core concept for
game from the beginning and thinking
about interactivity when you're
composing and doing sound effects on
because it's a whole whole different
animal yeah but the tests the demos are
totally legitimate we do them all the
time but uh sending some visuals along
is like very important for to making
sure you get what you want and then
we're able to kind of see what the game
is going to look like and then make that
decision otherwise we might write
something that we uh that you might not
have the vision for because we haven't
seen the art and maybe we could easily
do what you wanted but we just
misinterpreted it and went a different
direction so but yeah test legitimate
absolutely christiansen yep ha will you
be paid for a test or what if they are
guys say I'm curious
I mean we have not found that to be
extremely common with what we do we'd
like it to be more common it used to be
a thing yeah it used to be her like
still referred for commercials it was a
big butt paid for doing a demo I think
it's definitely more common a game world
in the film and TV world it's so
saturated with composers and sound
designers right now that they don't need
to because so many people want the work
um but um you know it's it is respectful
thing to do i think you know i SPECT if
it's a longer demo if it's a shorter
demo then it's like we're actually great
i mean like we're gonna keep the rights
that anyway so you could say like you
know a couple hundred bucks maybe but i
mean like it's if you're you know it's
not a required thing if we want the gig
you know we're happy to do a 30 second
demo to try and get it often it's nice
to throw a couple hundred bucks but it's
like at that point it's a couple hundred
bucks it's not like you know yeah it's
like it's you know it's pennies in the
grand scheme of things yeah if the
project is larger so yeah anyone
hopefully that is you find oh yeah yeah
pizza that's a big part of it now uh
yeah um we use the three things emotion
they function yeah i think i think the
biggest argument and that is probably
the mobile scene or it's like someone
sits on like in class like someone was
probably playing a mobile game during
our talk today um but uh you know it's a
big thing is like will do they just mute
that and then it's like yeah you could
say that but like some people do listen
to it when they do listen to it they
listen on headphones and we're at a talk
at a conference this year called game
sound with a composer named guy Whitmore
who did the music for peggle and peggle
2 and he was talking about there's not a
more intimate experience for audio than
in headphones you know or in that arena
but i think you know and in general on
it I mean it is undeniably important you
can put out a game it can do well with
you know a mobile game can do okay with
you know bad audio we're not gonna lie
that'll like that's a thing like flappy
bird but I believe ki love flappy bird
like I have like triple digit score on
flappy birds so um but but uh but you
know if you want
to set your game apart you know like
people look at that polished experience
they look at they look at you know if
we're talking about indie games they
look at something like journey or mobile
games you know something like peggle 2
they look at that in there like wow this
entire experience is super polished it's
super it's a great and it's broken down
the three parts really right it's it's
the functional it's to build them like
the mechanic of the game it's visual and
it's the audio and those are all a third
of the game and if you take out one of
those it's like you can solve a game if
you take out if you don't have great art
that's fine there's a lot of great games
that don't have great are if you don't
have a great mechanics okay maybe it's
pretty and sounds nice like Al still
sell that was a pie and you had people
over for a party would you hand them
only two-thirds of the pie to be like
crazy it's selfish so he said that cuz I
eat like a pie of favor is I eat a pie a
week as a whole nother but not seriously
so your game can function without one of
these things being great but like it's
not going to be as great an experience
so I are close it no I then I wasn't say
thank you again very much for us for
speaking to all students and lastly
we're having ya know I don't know you
feel free to put up our email addresses
mine is our ludlow and his is a forsberg
if you if you wanna ok hex nut oh yeah
perfect yeah cool and yeah feel free to
shoot us an email you know I mean if you
have any questions we're happy to you
know we're happy to support audio with
the new generation of developers so yeah
yeah and there's a lot of great people
over at Berkeley to you know like if
you're looking for composing sound
designers to collaborate with other
students there's a lot of great people
over there there's the video game music
club don't be afraid to cross the bridge
yes the video game music club they do a
lot of there's always like if you shoot
them an email you'll get like 10
responses from people who are like yes
let me like help you work on this game
like you're not getting paid I'm not
getting paid they might be like okay
with that yeah and I mean you guys have
the facilities for what you do in
Berkeley has a facility
true anyway but then you can call us
when you got paid yet so you know yeah
all right anyway well thanks so much i
really appreciate you guys caring about
audio really honestly really we really
appreciate people caring about music and
sound a little bit so thanks so much i
had luck with the rest of your semester
absolutely thanks see you guys around
good guys adios so yeah so on that note
if you are taking CMS 617 next semester
on the advanced game studio CMS 610 the
media arts industries blahhhh class both
of those are making a good polished
experience for the end of the front end
of the semester with the idea of either
showing it to publishers or submitting
it to a festival so audio is really
really important those two classes and
going to Berkeley for for that kind of
support is is highly recommended also
recommend in this class if you've got
the time as well and let us know if
you'd like more information about
connecting Berkeley folks yeah we
actually know the instructors and even
some some alums but the alums know the
people who are still in college video
game bosses if you'd like that contact
info otherwise you've got five minutes
to take a break back up with your teams
and hobble will be in at two o'clock
surprise three games